puis le mois de mars en fait le virus
cours devant et nous on court derrière
on a toujours un train de retard
en mars nous partons en crise avec 5000
lits de réanimation
nous sommes en octobre nous avons
toujours 5000 l'hydre et de monsieur
rien asseoir un de plus rien n'a changé
vous avez bien compris en réalité en
moins puisqu'il faut qu'on soigne les
autres qu'on avait pu soigner
non rien n'a changé il n'y a pas eu de
stratégie par exemple d'augmentation de
capacité d'hospitalisation
il n'y a pas eu de stratégie nationale
de test on a vu le chaos
y a pas eu de stratégie nationale
d'isolement moi je sais pas je j'aurai
une stratégie d'isolement
plutôt que de renvoyer les gens positifs
chez eux affectés tout leur entourage
les mettrait dans des hôtels
réquisitionné ce qui avait été envisagé
mais n'est jamais rentré en être mais ce
que vous pardon il souligne ce que vous
venez de dire il ya bien des choses qui
ont été sur la table et qu'on a dit
qu'on allait faire et qu'on n'a pas fait
regarder l'application stop que vides
qui ne fonctionne pas moi j'aurais aussi
une stratégie de vaccination
j'aurais bref une stratégie là où en
réalité comme n'y a pas de stratégie
nationale
la seule stratégie d de ceux qui nous
gouvernent cette demande et aux français
yassine effacés